what's up everyone persia here and i am
joined by jordan
and max and today we're gonna be talking
about some impressions that we've gotten
from our hands-on with season nine of
apex legends which is
pretty stacked i'm not gonna lie there's
a lot of stuff that comes with this
season
it ties into titanfall we've got a new
legend we've also got a brand new mode
which is completely different from
battle royale and
it's definitely gonna shake things up so
i'm excited to talk about it
we're so sorry that we can't show any
actual footage from our preview but
later on we will be able to so make sure
you like and subscribe so you can stay
tuned for all of that when it comes up
so we are going to jump right into it
arena mode is
amazing they've been teasing this
through ash and all of these little
in-game teasers
and now it's finally here arenas is a
three-on-three team battle
round based first to three points win by
two
and it's elimination base so once you
run out of that life that round you're
done
you have to purchase your weapons at the
start it's very reminiscent to cs go and
valerian
and you got to buy your abilities as
well so how do you guys feel about the
3v3 mode from what you've played
and is there anything surprising that
you notice so far i think it's amazing
that
apex is going to be basically two
completely
different games now like i think a lot
of people are looking at like oh it's
apex legends and now they have a new
arenas mode it's like no you
log into apex legends and it's like do
you want to play apex legends battle
royale do you want to play apex legends
arenas it's like arenas feels like a
completely
different game where abilities like
still matter team like teamwork still
matters like a lot of the core stuff
from the battle royale half like
translates over into arenas
but it feels like there's a bigger
emphasis on gun play
a bigger emphasis on making sure that
like your
team is more strategic in what lanes
they use as they're moving around the
maps you have so much of a smaller space
and like it's
it's basically like dropping hot like
dropping spicy and being like okay we've
landed here and there's one other team
and we basically have to use whatever
one
gun and little healing we have to take
them out to the best of our ability
and that's just a completely different
experience
to a full 20-minute battle royale
i enjoyed it a lot uh i think that the
the queue times and sometimes just like
dropping and dying over and over in the
br can be kind of grueling so like
getting like the
back-to-back action they can just get
right back into the fight in arenas is
something refreshing and new to apex
and i think it's kind of needed it was
in the works for
two years i think i think since 2019
something like that
yeah i think they said september 2019.
yeah so it's been
in the works for quite a while now and i
think they've ironed it out
enough for it to be working properly and
uh i think
everybody can agree during the play test
that it was a ton of fun for sure
there's definitely a sense of resource
management as well um because you can
like
not purchase heels and like save your
credits for like upgrading your guns and
then just
try to rush to the heels instead
the the cartons but then you're uh
you know you're sacrificing or possibly
risking not getting it or getting into a
fight without any heals
uh if the enemies beat you there first
so there's definitely like a kind of
like risk reward system
um on on where everybody's going on
which lane they pick
and which direction everybody's gonna
fight i think the uh
the ultimates in arenas is where things
get really fun you could do some awesome
combos in the play test i had
some teammates um we had a revenant we
had
valkyrie and i was horizon and we went
into revel
and then used valkyries all to fly up
into the air and land on the teammates
it was an
awesome combo and super fun and really
gets me thinking about how
team synergy is gonna be different in
arenas versus
the battle royale but this leads me to
valkyrie herself
i just mentioned the old so obviously we
can't go any further without talking
about this
character what did you guys think of
this character so far
max i know you got to use her a little
bit um i think we all managed to
at least get to play a couple of games
with her um so what did you think of her
so far
i think she's probably the coolest
character out of the bunch honestly
uh i yeah i'm i'm a wraith simp but i
think that
uh valkyrie is definitely like the
coolest
like smoothest uh persona out of all the
apex crew and
she definitely brings it with her kind
of like pilot aircraft persona
um she does have some voice lines that
pertain to like just being a pilot not a
titan
pilot but like just like a regular
aircraft pilot fox 3 and like call on
the ball there's like aircraft and
missile terms and
aviation so it works really well with
her kit um
she obviously has a pretty interesting
kit she has
three passives technically she's a recon
character so she can uh
use the uh recon beacons to
get more ring ring information she can
uh ping enemies while she
is uh dropping so that's pretty good to
kind of know
as long as they're in your line of sight
not behind cover but if you can see them
then they will be
pinged for you and then she also has her
veto hover kit so basically when
she uh when you press jump again in the
air then you hover
um i guess people are calling like like
pharah's hover i guess in a sense
um but uh it is
pretty risky in a fight because you are
going fairly slow and you can't like
strafe
very fast but it's definitely a good way
to get around
to higher ground and uh it's it's
pretty good honestly because you only
have it's not it's not using any
tactical per se it's just using a fuel
meter and that fuel meter
regains over time so you kind of use it
whenever you want which is really cool
it's almost interesting she kind of and
i mean this in a very positive way i
know someone's going to read this and be
like oh so she sucks and i'm like no no
like
she's almost like crypto in
a way where so much of what she's able
to do is wrapped solely
around the fact that she has like this
one specific gear like crypto is like
if you don't if he doesn't have his
drone he's not like a
very good character valkyrie is one of
those characters that like when she's on
the ground just fighting with normal
guns she's like
not incredibly useful but as soon as she
like takes off into the air with her
passive ability or just uses the passive
ability to get to a higher spot
where she can better rain down
destruction with her tactical ability
which
i assumed looking at the picture was
going to be closer to like a
cluster missile or something like that
it's like no no it's a lot more like the
north stars like flight core from
titanfall 2 like a smaller
condensed one um and so it's like a mini
bangalore
uh alts that you can use but it's like
not very good
if she's like standing on the ground you
kind of want to get above someone and
rain down the missiles from
above to try to get that ideal line of
sight to hit as many people as possible
with
the rockets and i think that's kind of
cool and it helps keep a character that
has something that sounds
as op as a jet pack from being too
op like it's not like when we were
starting with season seven and we were
looking at horizon skin we're like oh my
god this is like
incredibly overpowered it's like no
valkyrie is like a
instead of pathfinder trying to get
around horizontally valkyrie is very
like vertically
focused where it's like she wants to be
in the air as much as
possible to use her tactical and when
she's not in there using her tactical
she's using her passive to just like
get to like a certain location to like
try to
provide recon and support for the other
members of her squad
and so she's not overpowered not like
horizon at the start of season seven
well this horizon hey yummy relax
i love horizon she's one of my favorite
characters but of
every character that has come out like
since
season one horizon was the first like
one that
really came out i'm like you know
probably a little bit too strong she is
she is all right i'm not denying it i'm
not denying it
but speaking of maybe or maybe not
being op let's talk about some of the
other new stuff in a game
like the brand new weapon the bow check
a bow
it's in apex now what do you guys think
i know max
was singing some pretty high praises for
this gun but when i picked it up
i definitely put it right back down so
what do you think max
i think in the hands of the right type
of person it can be very deadly
um it is obviously like you would think
a bow and arrow is not as fast as a
bullet
even though it is still fairly fast so
you do have to lead your shots a bit
but the damage output is really high and
hands down the best part about it
is the audio it's fairly silent and
uh especially at long range it's really
hard to tell where the the shots are
coming from
so it is a pretty sneaky third party
tool
uh obvious obviously a range is when you
want to use it best and that's where it
excels
but it also can be used as a close range
weapon
it's not that great but it obviously is
just kind of like a
kind of a backup option but uh i think
in the top tier meta it may be a pretty
strong contender
i primarily used it to ambush other
squads just because getting off a quick
silent shot on people who aren't moving
all that well
can do devastating amounts of damage but
it's
so hard to track a fast character
with the arrow and if you can throw out
a bangalore smoke or
a caustic uh ultimate it's
hard to just see someone and line up the
shot like it's not
the oh i'm gonna get up in someone's
face and they have like a massive
shotgun
i'm gonna win this fight like maybe you
could if you're like really really good
at like dodging mastiff
shotgun blasts and if so please teach me
your ways
but it's it is a mid-range
weapon that can be used close range or
long range but does not like
excel like at those ranges interestingly
to mitigate that there is a new hop-up
called the shatter caps being added
that's kind of gonna help turn that shot
into something more reminiscent of a
shotgun
to kind of help with those close range
battles but along with the new shatter
caps
um which also can go on the 30 30
repeater
heads up for all the 30 30 represent
fans out there but
on top of that there's also dead eyes
tempo
somebody explain a little bit more about
that eye tempo here dead ice tempo is
kind of a way to
which can be attached to the bow check
or the sentinel can turn them into more
rapid fire weapons if you fire the
second
that the gun is ready to fire again so
on the bow check it's when the bow
string
is pulled back all the way and on the
sentinel it's when you
put another bullet into the
rifle chamber and there's like a little
meter that appears on your head when you
have that hop-up attached
so even if you can't like hear the bulls
the string being pulled back or hear the
sentinel
uh clicking or you just have a hard time
like getting the tempo down
you can like just look at the small
meter and just know
when the timing is for you to shoot
again and we did see a couple more
changes to
other guns like the g7 um
and the bow check and the triple take
and the 30 30 kind of having their own
weapon class
but also the peacekeeper is back on the
ground the triple take is in
the care package um so that's going to
be
really interesting i feel like we're
just coming full circle
peacekeepers back baby
everyone was sweating playing apex
legends for like the past three to four
seasons and like
didn't play apex at the very start they
don't know they don't know what's about
to happen
i know people are excited now give it a
couple of months in chapter this season
we'll see how we're feeling
right um the p2020 the mozambique the
wingman
and the longbow all got some buffs um
along with some character changes as
well low profile is
gone lifelines res shield is
gone aucting tactical hurts
more there's a lot of stuff oh yeah and
horizons lift
once again got hit with the nerf hammer
you're welcome guys
i know you guys all wanted it right
but she does a little wobble now when
she goes up the lift it's not
as fast as it used to be before but by
no means
ineffective it's still a great option
for her but
i can tell by the way they've made
valkyrie's jet
pack that they're kind of bringing it
more in line and a little bit more
balanced as opposed to making
valkyrie jetpack just as powerful as
lyft so
totally makes sense i'm here for it
another change
as we usually see with each new season
is that
olympus is also getting a little bit of
a revamp
a new point of interest um yeah olympus
is infested now take that as you will
there is some crazy stuff going on
there's like
dead crew members on this ship that
crashed on olympus
pretty crazy but also we got a little
vault 2.0
action as max calls it the other day
right
it basically is so like you said the
dead crew members are on board and uh
one of them has a key card and that's
basically the key to the vault at the
bulkheads so
i mean take what you will but that
sounds like a world's edge bowl to me
exactly so look forward to that it's
gonna be changing the landscape with
some creepy looking stuff
but it kind of looks like it's only the
beginning i don't think this is gonna be
the only change we're gonna see on
olympus as we
wrap up this impressions i'm just gonna
throw it out there for those
of you that i know we're wanting it
there's ground emotes now
and there's also going to be challenges
and badges and all this new stuff in
season nine that you guys
should tune into our channel for because
we're gonna have all the details on it
very very soon and like i said
in the beginning more footage on the way
once again thank you guys so much for
watching thank you jordan
thank you max you guys are the best
let's all go play apex and have a
great day peace out bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you